- - Merci beaucoup Marie-Eve!
- - C'est pas moi qui a gagné
dadans Taschereau c'est nous
auautres, c'est tout le monde
ququi a ici.
(a(applaudissements)
DoDonc Catherine était une des 0
dédéputés élus lors de la dernie
sosoirée électorale, bonsoir
CaCatherine.
LaLa passion et votre moteur, on
l'l'a vu des les premiers
ininstants, est-ce que la passin
vovous a quitté pour la politiq?
- - Pas du tout et je bois souvt
cecela en titre, je ne vois pas
leles choses comme cela, je suis
unune militante depuis 10 et 15
anans et je fais alors engager.
JeJe vais continuer sur ce chemn
enen étant plus présente sur le
teterrain, mais pour des luttes
cocomme la nécessité d'un tramwy
àà Québec ou des luttes de ce
gegenre, je serai là encore apr.
JeJe suis devenu une sorte
d'd'influenceuse dans la régione
QuQuébec et je vais continuer à
faface à.
JeJe peux me consacrer dans des
prprojets artistiques qui seront
enengagés.
- - Vous n'étiez pas devant un
dédébat qui se présente à
plplusieurs personnes, c'est-à-
didire si on doit se rester à
l'l'intérieur pour faire avancer
leles choses, poser des questio,
ouoù je sors et je peux encore
avavoir de l'influence?
- - Beaucoup de gens vont dire
ququ'est-ce qui est mieux?
OnOn peut se chicaner pour savor
s's'il faut aller à l'intérieur
popour faire pression, pour que
nonotre projet de société
réréussisse, pour l'environnemet
ouou pour la justice sociale, pr
quque ça se réussisse, nous avos
papas le choix d'être partout.
DaDans le monde artistique il ya
unune sorte de réveil politique
ququi va être très fécond et
auauquel j'ai envie de particip,
mamais en politique aussi il y a
unun retour vers la mobilisation
etet le lien avec le terrain.
- - Est-ce que c'est utile une
dédéputée Catherine Dorion?
- - C'est utile mais ça dépend e
ququ'on en fait.
J'J'aurais pu être pépère et alr
juste dans les souper spaghetti
etet dire que je n'ai pas de
popouvoir de j'ai décidé de faie
cece job avec tout ce que j'étas
etet avec tous les livres dits e
jeje pouvais m'imaginer.
EtEt faire pression sur les
miministres, mais il y a aussi
ororganisé des mobilisations coe
nonous allons faire de même pour
lele tramway, il y a près de 100
pepersonnes intéressées pour le
trtramway demain soir.
NoNous amenons des représentants
dede l'société civile, mais
dédéputée peut prendre
l'l'initiative et cela c'est be!
- - Je reviens avec l'exemple
trtramway, si vous étiez resté
dédéputé, si vous aviez continuà
poposer des questions dans les
cocommissions, faire des
reregroupements avec les
jojournalistes, est-ce que vous
n'n'auriez pas eu plus de pouvor
quque vous ne l'aurez comme
mimilitante dans des groupes?
- - C'est ce que la question de
ququi je vais avoir plus de
popouvoir?
JeJe ne suis pas en politique pr
avavoir du pouvoir mais pour
rerespirer et pour créer et pour
amamener de l'intelligence
émémotionnelle collective dans e
pepeuple, je veux participer à
cecela.
JeJe pense qu'on en a besoin et
ququi il y a des changements
sosociaux importants qui doivent
sese développer.
JeJe suis dans cette recherche t
seses maquettes, c'est ce qui me
fafait vivre.
AvAvoir le plus de pouvoir, ce
n'n'est pas ce que je cherche
cocomme personne.
JeJe cherche que les gens qui en
onont pas en est plus de gemmes
unune société où le pouvoir n'et
papas concentré en haut comme ls
enen ce moment.
- - Les gens qui vous ont élu, i
nene se sentent pas assez
prprésentés dans l'Assemblée
nanationale, il y a quand même n
momoins au bout de l'opération,
vovous allez dire à quelqu'un
d'd'autre sera là, mais ce que
vovous représentiez avec les trs
ququi choquaient les gens, ce
n'n'est pas important que ça ree
àà l'intérieur?
- Moi je fais ce pari, si jamais
cecela sur mes épaules en disant
ququ'il faut que je reste à
l'l'infini sinon ça ne sera plus
llà, c'est un mouvement et
d'd'autres personnes doivent
s's'engager et c'est un peu le
memessage que j'ai fait en sorte
mama vidéo.
SiSi vous trouvez que c'est trop
cocontraignant et que ce cadre
n'n'est pas pour vous, c'est pae
ququ'on a besoin de voir
popolitique.
IlIl faut des gens qui veulent
pépéter des cadres.
JeJe suis fier de ces quatre
anannées et le message que j'ai
fafait à tous les québécoish et
alallez-y!
PlPlus vous êtes différent et ps
vovous êtes important pour aller
dadans cette institution il sinn
sisi on laisse les gens qui aimt
cecette institution et qui
babaissent confirmer, on est
fofoutu.
- - Mais partir, vous dîtes quee
n'n'est pas être un peu foutu?
CeCe n'est pas renoncé?
- - Pas du tout, comme je dis un
pepeu partout, il y a plein de
mimilieux qui ont besoin
d'd'implication.
ReRené Lévesque avait eu une
didiscussion à 10 ans à Fernand
DuDumont qu'il fallait qu'il
s's'implique et Fernand Dumont
didisait qu'il y avait besoin de
mimilitants dans le milieu
arartistique